hoy empieza el esperado y controvertido
viaje de michelle bachelet a china el
primero de un alto comisionado en el
gigante asiático en 17 años más el de no
pisar a beijing que está en un estado de
semi confinamiento debido a un brote de
coronavirus pero sí estará en kashgar y
oro en las dos principales ciudades de
xinjiang su misión es investigar sobre
la situación de la etnia minoritaria
uigur es un asunto que divide por un
lado a las organizaciones de derechos
humanos y algunos gobiernos occidentales
y por el otro a china los primeros
aseguran que ahí se cometen graves
violaciones de derechos humanos como la
reclusión forzosa de hasta un millón de
augures en centros de reeducación china
sin embargo sostiene que esos centros ya
están cerrados y que sirvieron para
luchar contra el terrorismo la finalidad
de la oficina de la alta comisionada
desde que el viaje empezará a negociarse
hace cinco años atrás es tener libre
acceso a todas las instalaciones y poder
entrevistarse con la población local las
organizaciones de derechos humanos sin
embargo dudan de que las autoridades
chinas vayan a permitir un viaje
independiente con todas las garantías el
día 28 el último de su estancia en china
ofrecerá una rueda de prensa con las
conclusiones sobre su viaje en china